quel rôle peuvent jouer les grands fonds
et les investisseurs dans la protection
de la biodiversité hier à la COP15 avait
lieu la première journée consacrée à la
finance dans le but de rassemblée des
financiers du monde entier autour de cet
enjeu là un joueur de chez nous
fondation y était avec nos Geneviève
Morin et PDG de fondation bonsoir madame
Morin bonsoir madame donc vous faites
partie de la délégation de fondation à
la coque 15 vous y êtes présente depuis
quelques jours quel est votre rôle celui
de fondation lors de cette réunion en
fait nous on participe à cette Cope là
avec trois grands objectifs le premier
c'est qu'on fait partie de l'Alliance
internationale que ce soit des
investisseurs d'impact ou des
investisseurs qui s'engagent à investir
un biodiversité et ces gens-là sont en
ville en ce moment donc on a l'occasion
de parler avec les membres des autres
membres de ces organisations-là
resserrer les liens un peu échanger
deuxième grand objectif faire connaître
ce qu'on fait ce qu'on réalise ici même
au Québec et
faire connaître donc ses capacités là
par exemple on a parlé cette semaine
beaucoup de notre projet des indicateurs
de biodiversité pour les financiers
intervenez mais qui qui est un projet
collectif collaboratif qui se passe au
Québec et troisièmement on cherche aussi
à apprendre il y a pendant ces
conférences là des panels de discussions
des conférences on peut rencontrer des
gens auxquels on n'aurait pas
normalement accès on apprend énormément
alors c'est très très enrichissant donc
c'est parce que quand on parle de
finance madame Morin la biodiversité et
pas toujours quelque chose qui nous
vient en tête de quelle manière des
investissements peuvent avoir un impact
on parle souvent d'environnement on
mesure ça avec l'empreinte carbone mais
de quelle manière les investissements
peuvent avoir un impact sur la
biodiversité en particulier la faune la
flore bon ben on peut d'un côté on peut
avoir des impacts négatifs
malheureusement quand on finance des
entreprises de fabrication de pesticides
ou celles qui sortent les énergies
fossiles de l'autre côté on peut avoir
des effets positif quand on appuie des
entreprises par exemple on a une filière
à fond d'action dans l'alimentation
durable donc les entreprises qui font du
bio qui font du diversifier qui
s'assurent également d'utiliser des
bons travail à des chaînes ou les
déchets des uns deviennent les intrants
des autres avec l'économie circulaire
donc quand on pense comme ça on est
capable de régénérer la biodiversité et
de s'assurer que la nature va être
capable de combler nos besoins encore
pendant de nombreuses années bon vous
êtes un fond vous investissez il y a
bien des investisseurs qui se disent ce
sont de beaux concepts ce sont de belles
idées mais souvent on fait des
placements des investissements pour le
rendement est-ce qu'on doit opposer
l'environnement la biodiversité et se
rendement là madame Morin mais en fait
nous on est convaincu que il va falloir
que l'économie devienne plus équitable
plus inclusive et plus verte et donc les
entreprises qui offrent des solutions
qui amènent vers ça on est sincèrement
celles qui vont réussir dans le futur
l'exemple facile c'est de se dire quand
on un changement climatique il y a une
dizaine d'années si je disais à
quelqu'un tu as le choix entre avoir des
actions d'une compagnie pétrolière ou
d'une compagnie d'énergie renouvelable à
l'époque on pouvait hésiter mais
aujourd'hui c'est très clair que c'est
les actions de la compagnie d'énergie
renouvelable qui ont de l'avenir alors
c'est la même chose avec les
biodiversité ça commence c'est plus
jeune mais c'est une tendance d'avenir
parce qu'on a besoin de s'assurer que la
nature se régénère suffisamment pour
maintenir et continuer à répondre aux
besoins donc rendement futur peut-être
rendement présent est-ce que c'est le
cas rendement présent également oui nous
en tout cas le rendement de fondation
est tout à fait comparable avec toutes
les compétiteurs parce que on réussit à
faire les choses d'une manière en fait
nous la façon dont on regarde les choses
on se dit qu'est-ce qu'il y a besoin
d'être fait pour que la société
s'améliore et comment on rend ça
rentable et on invente avec ça des
solutions nouvelles en matière de
financement mais qui rapportent
parce qu'on se souvient bien qu'on a 200
000 actionnaires qui comptent sur nous
pour prendre leur retraite puis on fait
très attention à l'argent clairement ça
c'est le virage ou les choix que vous
avez fait à fond d'action on disait
c'était une première journée associée à
la finance qui a eu lieu hier est-ce que
les autres grands font les grands
financiers qui étaient présents est-ce
qu'ils sont ouverts à cette approche là
alors de plus en plus avec toute la
préoccupation des
pour que la prise en compte des éléments
environnementaux sociaux et de
gouvernance les gens de la finance
s'intéressent il faut se dire que
c'était hier la première journée de la
finance dans une coop sur la
biodiversité et on est pourtant rendu à
la 15e donc il y en a 14 autres qui se
sont passés de la finance mais là tout à
coup il y a de l'intérêt pour ça pour
aller plus loin pour en apprendre
davantage le projet par exemple des
indicateurs de biodiversité suscitent
beaucoup d'intérêts parmi les
investisseurs au Québec les financiers
l'idée c'est que quand on parle de
biodiversité il y a une dimension très
très locale c'est la biodiversité du
Québec celle de l'Afrique c'est pas la
même il faut sauver les deux donc quand
on est des financiers du Québec il faut
travailler sur quoi c'est important de
comprendre et pour qu'on puisse
comprendre nous ce qu'on a fait c'est
qu'on a mis ensemble grâce à nos
partenaires aussi à des organisations de
protection de la nature des chercheurs
universitaires et des gens
d'institutions financières de plusieurs
institutions financières et on travaille
tous ensemble à déterminer c'est quoi
les priorités sur quel indicateurs on
devrait travailler le plus rapidement
possible au Québec pour préserver notre
propre biodiversité en souhaitant les
retombées pour la biodiversité et pour
vos investisseurs vos actionnaires merci
beaucoup d'avoir été là madame merci
beaucoup madame pour voir nos émissions
en entier rendez-vous sur la chaîne ici
RDI
[Musique]